Футбол
єдиний по довідковому світові бути
спорту на екрані підтвердження цього в
проведенні ліги Європи за на грають
профіт засіву кольору
продажів права на трансляцію матчу в так і
клубом у краще дніпро і будці на
прокладку наступна муси зоні бундесліга
планової заруби ти на водах стала
компаніями на 2 700 мільйонів євро
близько мільярда розруху а вранці це
іспанська приклад дивізіон
Яків пишу 1 по 9
централізовано
раніше реал і барселона продавав і права
на показ своїх матчів
про креми без за порочний лідер
англійська прем'єр-ліга
в життя нас тут на уроку за рубль від
імана трансляціях на 3 мільярди євро
зараз і зону за право транслювати та
матч цього каналу конкуру Аліна і більше
ланцюга дня лот сини
грішний конкурс виграв і sky the
british telecom випуск європейський
футбол зростання і терпи прем'єр-ліга ціна
іж вище
менше моїх очей не проблеми контракти
англійських клубі керують жирок
доларів ти в манчестер юнайтед на
прикладну сюди на праведно всі капітан
німецької збірної бастіан швайнштайгер
амід я тут отжиманий юнайтед великий
клуб я хочу врат і ук найкраще лізі
святої церкви charge me
найкраща лігів світла cool edit sap
рожеві вони титули тут іспанські клуби
може дати фору всім за астані 5 роки
он і 34 могла полетіти чемпіонів уефа і
трич і у лізи Європи на всьому від лідуся
на не команд прем'єр-ліги
то бундесліги виражають менше
а зараз для dodge а ми тут бундесліга
наріжте обходити всі мечі на травень
фантастично системи продажів iv аншлагу на
стадіонах старий йому 40000 для дачі у
продовжувати про термін у бундесліга
я перший завідування матчі в Європі на
матчі мюнхенської баварії дортмундської
борусії та валик з гумки рк н.а.
купіть квиток практично не можеш
воював